[Música]
caminando
e inteligencia artificial héroe o
amenaza esas eran las palabras que le
decía el jefe de peter parker cuando le
entregaba las primeras fotos del hombre
araña y se decidían por el encabezado de
mañana
todos sabemos que peter parker es el
hombre araña pero aquí él se mostraba un
poco sorprendido hasta ofendido porque
si él era el héroe y él hacía las cosas
bien porque bien este señor a decirme
que soy una amenaza así me siento yo un
poquito cuando me dicen que le tienen
miedo a la inteligencia artificial
pero entonces por qué digo que la
inteligencia artificial puede ser una
amenaza es segura o es más bien
peligrosa me puede quitar mi trabajo o a
lo mejor simplemente es eso que los
programadores dicen para no decirnos qué
es lo que tiene su solución
no
pues nada más que nada no me dejará
mentir que el común denominador de la
inteligencia artificial es este que nos
ofrecen las películas por ejemplo
la audición del espacio terminator ese
clásico donde skynet quería acabar con
la raza humana o una más contemporánea y
un poquito más menos a ser que es donde
este señor se enamora de su computadora
y en la lectura también tenemos varios
varios ejemplos pero el más sonado es a
isaac asimov con yo robot donde nos
enseñó que los robots son tan capaces de
pensar por ellos mismos que hasta
fundaron su religión y se rebelaron
contra los humanos
entonces por donde podemos empezar a
desentrañar todas estas preguntas que
hice al principio pues precisamente por
ahí por el principio con una definición
la inteligencia artificial es la
capacidad de un agente no vivo de pensar
ahora en español la inteligencia
artificial es una rama de la
programación que nos hace posible que
las computadoras aprendan enseñarles
cosas conceptos y que los aprendan y que
captan también aprendan de sus errores y
sobre todo que sean mejores que las
personas para hacer estas tareas que he
visto de esta manera estas computadoras
si son más inteligentes que uno porque
ellos si aprenden de sus errores si se
vuelven menos mejores computadoras y no
tienen que ir a terapia entonces
vamos a poner algo sencillo
y yo aquí les voy a mostrar no de
fotografías y si yo les preguntara
díganme en cuáles fotos hay gatos y en
cuáles no ustedes me dirán sabes que hay
fotos en los gatos están en la 1 en las
5 y en las 7 esto es algo que como
decían en las charlas anteriores el
humano siempre ha sido un maestro un
genio que es
reconocer patrones si para eso la
inteligencia especial tiene muchas
dificultades sobre todo porque no sé si
ustedes se acuerdan cómo supieron que
era un gato seguramente lo vieron por
ahí en la calle lo vieron en un libro o
en una fotografía le preguntaban a mamá
mamá qué es eso les dijo es un gato y de
allí es un concepto que está allá en
nuestra cabeza y va a ser muy difícil
que se les olvide si no es que imposible
para las computadoras no es tan sencillo
y esa es la diferencia primordial entre
la inteligencia artificial y la natural
que nosotros humanos nos basta con ver
23 ejemplos a veces hasta 1 para poder
extraer un concepto e integrarlo a
nuestra mente para las computadoras no
es tan sencillo las computadoras
necesitan una cantidad enorme de datos
para poder hacer estas tareas vamos a
poner el ejemplo de los datos si yo
quiero que una computadora me diga en
cuáles de estas nueve imágenes hay gatos
pues va a tener que hacer una serie de
procedimientos antes que serían yo
programador le voy a dar muchísimas
fotos donde no hay y no hay dónde hay
no hay datos tienen que ser sí se puede
miles cientos millones como sea después
esta computadora va a aprender cómo se
ve un gato y distinguirlo de su entorno
la carita los bigotes las orejas la cola
de qué color es típicamente un gato
donde suelen estar en las escenas de las
fotografías y después yo le voy a hacer
esa computadora un examen pero más que
un examen es una autoevaluación porque
yo le doy las respuestas y las preguntas
después la computadora me dice sabes que
me saqué un 6 60 por ciento de
efectividad ay me toca a mí al maestro
al programador corregir hacer darle
otras instrucciones para que sea cada
vez mejor claro a lo mejor no puede
alcanzar el 100% pero si se va a volver
mucho mejor que un humano para reconocer
estas imágenes
hasta ahora todo suena muy interesante
pero a poco la inteligencia artificial
es tan peligrosa que me va a quitar ese
trabajo que he tenido 20 años de
clasificador experto de imágenes de
gatos pues no realmente ese miedo que
nosotros tenemos viene de algo que se
llama el complejo de frankenstein es
como lo dice su nombre es un complejo
donde el creador siente que su creación
no puede superar como le pasó
precisamente el doctor víctor
frankenstein cuando dijo cuando su
monstruo le dijo tú podrás ser mi
creador pero ahora yo soy tu amo
y ese tipo de cosas son las que nos
meten el miedo y nos impiden
hablar de inteligencia artificial y no
es para menos porque hay unos ejemplos
muy terroríficos de cómo funciona la
inteligencia artificial
aquí vemos a tom cruise y está bien ahí
está tom cruise pero como que algo le
pasa está como raro como que no sé yo me
imagino que tom cruise es más alto o
como que está más fornido o no sé ese es
el problema esta persona está un cruz es
un doble se usa una técnica que se llama
deep fake que estaba bastante de moda en
internet que se trata de usar el vídeo
de la cara de una persona se había
muerta y montarlo en otro vídeo de otra
persona o sea ese es el cuerpo de una
persona es otra es otro y su cara es la
de tom cruise y en estos vídeos si lo
pudiéramos ver se apreciaría como al
principio se cae es un vídeo muy común
se cae se ríe se levanta y bromea
después hay un clip donde se pone un
sombrero unos lentes empiezo a jugar
golf y uno donde hace magia con una
moneda todo este vídeo se trata de eso
de que interfiere con el cual la imagen
de vídeo cuando tú pones algo así con
los filtros de snap sado de instagram
haces así y se quitan este no es
precisamente eso lo que quieren
demostrar en este vídeo se imaginan
ustedes todos los problemas legales
políticos o sociales que puede tener
esto es una invasión a la privacidad
otro muy padre es este que se llama
dispersión 2 no existe punto com es una
página donde si yo voy a esa página
pero aquí está no pasa nada fuera de lo
vital es una
persona y cada que yo pico el botón de
referencia al de una persona nueva eso
no tiene nada de raro
lo raro sería que estas personas no
existen estas personas hay una
inteligencia artificial detrás que tiene
bases de datos de cómo la estructura de
una cara y hace caras nuevas esta
persona no lo van a encontrar en el
mundo porque no existe y un poco de
miedo un poco de novela de terror
y junto con esos ejemplos tenemos muchos
otros
como es el de facebook cuando yo subo
una fotografía y me dice quieres
etiquetar a tu amigo pedro oa pablo oa
rafael conoce a nuestros amigos xavi que
son nuestros amigos conoce sus caras y
todavía tiene el descaro de decirnos lo
quieres etiquetar es una un poco de
invasión a la privacidad aunque no
porque cuando ustedes crearon su
facebook le dieron permiso de eso más
ejemplos podrían ser pues el armamento
automático las estas tías que juegan
juegos y ganan les ganan a los humanos
en ajedrez en go en adivina quién lo que
sea
todas estas amenazas que puede que nos
reemplacen en algún momento
y no es para menos porque si va a pasar
yo no les voy a mentir si va a pasar
pero vamos a hablar de eso un poco más
adelante porque precisamente todos estos
ejemplos son malos pero lo que yo les
quiero decir es que más bien es fundado
en una ideología mala porque eso me hace
recomenzar dar un profe que tener en la
primaria que siempre nos decía quién es
más inteligente una calculadora con
nosotros después estábamos en la
primaria nosotros pensábamos muchos
nuevos las calculadoras y él siempre nos
decía no nosotros porque nosotros
inventamos las calculadoras algo tan
sencillo como eso pero con una dirección
con un sentido es lo que necesitamos
para desarrollar inteligencia artificial
todos esos ejemplos que yo les puse la
inteligencia artificial no decidió ser
irresponsable o mala o invadir la
privacidad de alguien lo decidió una
persona esas personas que crean las
inteligencias artificiales lo hacen con
unos principios específicos y un uso si
tú haces mal uso de eso ya es problema
de los demás pero también el tuyo
siempre hay que tener unos principios
éticos fuertes y sobre todo una buena
ideología y hacer buen uso de las cosas
usar las cosas para las que son
necesarias o para lo que fueron
diseñadas
en ejemplos un poco más alegres tenemos
el área médica todos conocemos los
tomógrafos esos tomógrafos espero que
nunca hayan tenido que pasar por una
sesión de ellos a veces te puedes tú
tardar hasta una hora o más en esos
aparatos son unos aparatos que toman
secciones del cuerpo en imágenes si
nosotros tenemos una guía una
inteligencia artificial podemos tomar
los datos históricos de los pacientes
que estén dispuestos a donar los de sus
tomografías crear una guía que aprenda
la estructura de las imágenes y después
creé imágenes pero con 75% menos datos
eso qué quiere decir que si me tardaba
una hora va a tardar 15-20 minutos
entonces el aparato puede atender a más
personas las personas no están tanto
tiempo y sobre todo la ayuda a los
adultos mayores y los niños que tienen
dificultades quedándose que otros tanto
tiempo
lo otro es la radiología o imagenología
como le llamamos en esta ciencia los
rayos x si nosotros hacemos lo mismo
tomamos datos de los rayos x y tenemos
una máquina que está dañado a lo mejor
no tiene muy buena calidad podemos crear
imágenes fieles con menos datos también
o hasta otra cosa si tú te rompiste un
brazo o tienes la sospecha puede tomar
una foto y dependiendo de la curvatura
que hay en las fotos le puedes decir si
tenés el vaso roto o no pero sin
radiografía esa es otra que
nadie perdón es este otro es la
identificación de patología y síntomas y
síntomas lleva el doctor yo digo que
tengo me receta y me dice tienes esto
tienes una infección qué tal que hacemos
historia juntamos las historias clínicas
y las historias familiares de pacientes
relacionamos patologías con síntomas y
después los juntamos y yo nada más
describen mis síntomas y a mí me
prescribe un medicamento o me dicen que
tengo pero si bien el doctor
eso también es bastante interesante
otros ejemplos que sería la cirugía
automatizada robótica
y muchos ejemplos biológicos que
realmente no es necesario enumerar
dentro del tema dentro del ámbito de la
optimización tenemos google maps a quien
no le ha pasado que viene bien tranquilo
va para su trabajo y se pasa la vuelta o
se sigue de frente toda la vuelta para
el otro lado si ustedes tienen el mapa y
esperan dos segundos les va a recalcular
y les va a decir su nueva ruta y esa
ruta siempre va a ser la óptima la que
les tome menos tiempo otro ejemplo que
también lo personal también me gusta
mucho porque yo no sé dibujar soy
malísimo para dibujar es out otro que se
lo voy a mostrar
aquí mismo lo que podemos hacer es es un
lienzo es un lienzo cualquiera aquí está
entonces que hago yo voy a hacer un
carrito no ya hemos quedado yo lo va a
hacer como me lo enseñaron en el kinder
una llanta otra llanta si se fijan y una
carcasa si se fijan en la parte de
arriba van apareciendo cosas que son
sugerencias entonces cuando yo termino
de dibujar mi figurita
yo puedo convertirlo en algo un poco más
profesional
si eso es un poco ya salvavidas para
cuando necesito hacer cosas rápido
entonces tenemos el ejemplo de la otra
tenemos muchos otros ejemplos pero
ahorita vamos a usar uno de mis
favoritos que es la detección de imagen
de emociones entonces le va a pedir a
una personita que ya hablé con ella que
pase aquí que se arrime el escenario y
vamos a hacer una prueba
se me permiten un poco de songs
de su tiempo
y aquí vamos a ver esto y vamos a ver la
cámara y yo quiero que pongan atención
aquí abajo casi no se ve pero pongan la
mayor atención que ustedes puedan los
inquietos del cubrebocas por favor ahora
pues sonreír
me apunté triste una hora en hoja t
ahora ponga la de las compras
y por último en hojas otra vez con cara
de miedo de sorpresa bueno
eso es lo que está pasando no se ve
mucho porque está me lo tapa las letras
pero eso es identificación de emociones
con la cara de mi asistente mía podemos
detectar sus emociones con la estructura
de su cara y ustedes dirán no hizo para
qué nos sirve les voy a dar dos ejemplos
qué tal que eso lo ponemos en un salón
de clases y vemos qué clases español
matemáticas tecnología le dan miedo a
los alumnos o les gusta o lo sorprenden
o los hace enojar y con eso corregimos
las actitudes negativas e incentivamos
las positivas uno que me gusta en lo
personal más yo cuando voy a una tienda
de ropa mí no me gusta que me atiendan
yo voy a dar mi ropa ya luego le digo
cobre me no me gusta que se te ve muy
bien eso no me gusta entonces qué tal
que es un asistente robótico que sirve
tu cara de disgusto que se viene
acercando y en la persona cara de
disgusto se va
eso sería bastante interesante y es algo
por lo que yo sí pagaría
volviendo a la presentación
una disculpa artista
ya lo vemos ya logramos
entonces eso es ya hemos visto ejemplos
buenos malos y demás pero lo que sí en
realidad es que en el mediano plazo el
74% de los estadounidenses están
preocupados porque en ese mediano plazo
la inteligencia artificial se iba a
tomar los trabajos que son eminentemente
mecánicos y repetitivos los cajeros de
los súper la conducción de autobuses de
transporte privado las líneas de
producción todo eso que puede hacer una
máquina las costuras en los pantalones
en la ropa lo va a ser pero lo bueno es
que estamos aprendiendo eso justo ahora
en el largo plazo
vamos a necesitar siempre gente que se
imagina una mejor inteligencia
artificial o que mejore las que ya
existen siempre vamos a necesitar gente
y por eso les pido yo encarecidamente
que estudien una rama de la programación
aprendan a programar no encuentra si
tienen 30 40 50 años en los trabajos de
hoy en día se aprecia más la capacidad
que tienes de investigar y de olvidar
los conceptos que no te sirven que de
recordar lo que ya habías aprendido y
sobre todo no tengan miedo y sean
curiosos porque la curiosidad más que la
valentía
de los miembros muchas veces
[Aplausos]